[Musique]
bonsoir à tous au golf national de
saint-quentin vélodrome nous avons
plusieurs infrastructures candidat tant
pour les jo de 2024 fitness park bodiot
mou encore machine fitness-club
plusieurs salles de sport fleurissent
sur le territoire il ya donc une
véritable économie
vous l'aurez compris le saut 7,8 et qu
est dédié au sport faune maire fidesz
part que boodoom fitness ont encore et
lancia il ya plus d'une vingtaine de
sacs de sport sur le territoire et
d'autres sont encore à venir
nous ferons un point sur ce business
l'ancienne championne de natation
anne-sophie le paranthoën a créé des
sports théo un site où vous pouvez
acheter et vendre du matériel de sport
d'occasions et puis nous avons
interviewé paulienne hermitage le
directeur du golf national nous verrons
avec lui pourquoi la ryder cup 2018 est
une chance économique pour le territoire
d'après l'insee il existe des milliers
de salles de sport en france on assiste
à un véritable boom dans ce secteur ils
ont plein entre 15000 et 18 mille
salariés le chiffre d'affaires s'élève à
1 milliard d'euros
saint quentin en yvelines n'échappe pas
à cet engouement deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien
en quelques années plusieurs salles de
sport ont fleuri sur le territoire on en
dénombre plusieurs dizaines et d'autres
sont encore à venir
regardez faisons un petit point sur les
salles de sport du territoire il y à
bougnol fitness à mort pas là pour coeur
de cible la musculation et de cardio
le prix de base est de 27 euros par mois
avec des frais d'inscription de 49 euros
90 il est aussi et lancia montigny le
bretonneux sur la même gamme de prix
elle propose de son côté des programmes
d tox garder la ligne ou encore de la
préparation physique et puis il y as
fitness park qui se revendique comme une
salle de sport low cost mais de qualité
c'est à dire sans frais d'inscription et
vous déboursez 29 euros par mois the
machine fitness club et une salle
premium qui se trouve à guyancourt
pour sa directrice les prix s'adapte à
la qualité des services énormément
d'accompagnement que de l'accompagnement
avec des coachs en permanence du matin
au soir
aucun cours vidéo avec effectivement de
conseil que cela soit sportive jusqu'à
la nutrition jusqu'aux programmes
diététiques et tout ce qui s'ensuit et
nous femmes sur le plateau avec
frederick henderson coach sportif à
saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir bonsoir à tous dites moi à quel
sale
il faut que je m'inscrive les prix
varient entre 29 et 79 euros il ya des
pois je peux courir je peux être raciste
et comment on fait pour choisir
déjà il faut commencer par définir quels
objectifs on cherche à atteindre
dire que par exemple si on cherche à
faire de la musculation évidemment
investir dans le matériel soi même ça
coûte cher
donc c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
rentable d'être un espèce de leasing
aller à une salle de musculation qui est
là tous les équipements qu'on ne
pourrait pas s'offrir soi même et ça
permet d'accéder pendant donc tout
confort de profiter des équipements et
de faire sa musculation comme on veut
après ce qu'on est uniquement intéressé
par la musculation au quelqu'un sera pas
trop regardant sur la présence ou non de
deux classes de cours comme le rpm ou
des cours de zumba où différents types
de cours que peuvent offrir les pas
offrir les salles et évidemment pas ce
coup là va être répercutée aussi sur
l'abonnement alors faut bien payer des
entraîneurs alors on sait qu'en moyenne
les français déboursent par mois pour
des séances de sport 59 euros quelle
salle il faut choisir est ce que cette
somme c'est assez pour pouvoir faire le
corps qu'on veut
qu'on souhaite là encore ça va dépendre
aussi de votre niveau de maîtrise de
l'activité se dire que si vous êtes
vraiment débutant ce sera intéressant
d'aller dans une salle avec des avec des
entraîneurs comme elle disait dans le
comme la dame ne racontez dans le dans
le documentaire pendant le reportage
ils ont toujours des entraîneurs sur le
plateau musculation on a pris le
contrôle de la zone de musculation donc
si on a besoin d'être si on a besoin de
conseils et si on n'est pas sûr on a
toujours quelqu'un vers qui se tourner
et à qui demander il ya d'autres salles
plus low cost où il n'y a pas cette
présence là où on est un peu plus livré
à soi-même
donc c'est vrai que même si ça coûte
moins cher peut-être qu'on aura pas
l'encadrement et l'accompagnement
nécessaires pour progresser notre moi
par exemple j'ai pas forcément besoin
d'eux une ribambelle de services annexes
que d'autres personnes peuvent
rechercher
ça aussi ça rentre dans le et pour finir
sur cette partie on sait que les banques
ont vraiment beaucoup de mal à ces
derniers temps à donner des crédits à de
nouvelles salles de sport 59 euros il ya
des prêts à 79
est ce que il ya eu ce qu'il faut pas
faire attention pour les bancs au nom
pour la personne qui veut s'inscrire
dans une salle
oui bien sûr il faut bien regarder le
contrat la durée minimum d'engagement
s'il ya plus généralement quand on
s'inscrit c'est ces contractuels sur au
moins douze mois c'est à dire que comme
pour le coup pour le téléphone au final
on peut pas se désengager avant la fin à
moins qu'ils aient une raison comme un
déménagement et raisons professionnelles
par on n'est plus capable de payer
l'abonnement
si on prenait des justificatifs
certaines salles de sport accepte donc
il faut bien regarder les petites
lettres sur le sur le contrat
d'abonnement
voir aussi est ce qu'il n'ya pas moyen
de négocier puisque seront il ya un
il ya des frais de dossier oui les frais
d'inscription les fameux on finira sur
sa qui sont des fois gratuits ou qui
coûte 100 euros parce qu'en fait ça
correspond à rien on va finir sur sa
merci on vient d'apprendre quelque chose
un peu mal sur le territoire nous avons
des athlètes de haut niveau tels que
tony yoka en boxe
thomas baruch en aviron françois pervis
cycliste mais tous ne gagne pas des
millions la plupart de nos représentants
au jour gagne très souvent le smic c'est
à dire environ 1300 euros
c'est pour cette raison qu'il pensait
une reconversion après l'ancienne
championne de natation anne-sophie le
paranthoën a créé des sports et au un
site où vous pouvez acheter et vendre du
matériel de sport d'occasions regardez
une reconversion professionnelle 2.0
l'ancienne nageuse anne-sophie le
parenté ont ex coéquipière de laure
manaudou est licencié au cercle des
nageurs de marseille vient de créer une
place de marché sur internet le site est
dédié à l'achat et à la vente de
matériels et d'équipements sportifs
d'occasion une idée longtemps mûri par
l'ancien athlète
pourquoi pas parce que je trouve que
déjà un mois je voulais entreprendre et
je voulais être
indépendante donc donc voilà
entreprendre et après je vois le sport
parce que j'ai toujours fait du sport et
que c'est quand même l'élément je
maîtrise le mieux et que je connais
mieux et avec tout le réseau que j'avais
je me suis dit ça serait dommage de ne
pas en profiter pour lancer son projet
là sportif de 40 ans qui habite à
rocquencourt a décidé de s'associer à
son ami de 33 ans paulino j'ai un projet
né à l'époque où les deux
collaboratrices travailler ensemble au
conseil départemental des yvelines
ça fait 4 4 ans qu'on travaille ensemble
donc voilà progressivement on a appris à
se connaître et puis on avait des on se
complétait bien dans nos compétences on
s'entendait bien donc
donc on sait on s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré lancée au mois de février
dans la zone d'activités promo paul à
montigny le bretonneux d'exporter au
contient déjà plus de 3000 références
d'ici la fin de l'année plus de vingt
mille produits seront disponibles sur le
site internet pour booster le nombre de
clics des partenariats avec des sportifs
célèbres sont à l'étude
alors on le sait nos eaux
nos joueurs audio gagne la plupart du
temps le smic et y en a qui réussissent
très bien comme cette dame qui a fait
son site internet
comment on fait derrière y'a vraiment
des réussites après le sport et gagne
combien alors ça ça va aussi dépendre du
sport dans lequel on vient donc ça veut
dire question bien un sport olympique où
il n'y a pas énormément de fonds bat
c'est là où on retrouve les sportifs de
haut niveau qui sont à mi temps derrière
et c'est vraiment un boulot alimentaire
qu'ils puissent survivre en même temps
qu'ils poursuivent leur carrière
sportive
et c'est vrai que derrière ça peut être
plus compliqué parce qu'une fois que la
glace la carrière sportive s'arrête et
il veut le faire autre chose et c'est
vrai que s'ils sont pas préparés à
l'avancé ils vont se retrouver devant le
fait accompli et c'est là que ça peut
être plus compliqué alors que si on
commence à se préparer pendant sa
carrière sportive à la reconversion si
on peut faire du networking si on peut
trouver des appuis financiers pour
lancer son entreprise comme on a vu dans
le reportage ça ça peut être plus facile
mais ça demande de la préparation et
c'est vrai que souvent les sportifs de
haut niveau ont tendance à oublier
qu'ils sont jamais que une blessure de
la retraite et c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment important pour ces sportifs là
de se reconvertir pour des footballeurs
qui ont gagné des millions pendant leur
carrière on en parle souvent mais
c'est une tellement une minorité pour
rarement des de ce genre de problème de
plusieurs joueurs de rugby par peter de
villiers il s'est reconverti et dans le
dans le rugby le coach un encadrement du
sport parce que c'est sa vie sa carrière
et en parallèle il a investi dans en
afrique du sud dans dans l'immobilier je
crois donc qu'il a dans les villes il ay
la différentes portes de sortie sinon on
a aussi jamie cudmore qui lui sa
reconversion elle sait tout fait il
arrête cette année sa carrière de
rugbyman à oyonnax il passe dans le
staff tout de suite derrière
mais ça il peut le faire que parce que
c'est un rugby et il ya les moyens de
rémunérer les couches derrière eh bien
merci frederick henderson d'être resté
sur le plateau avec nous d'ailleurs vous
restez on va passer à un autre sujet on
le disait en début d'émission on a
beaucoup de complexes sportifs
d'envergure à saint quentin en yvelines
qui candidate pour les jo de 2024 c'est
le cas du golf national
il recevra aussi la ryder cup cette
compétition ses 540 millions de
téléspectateurs dans 180 pays et un
nombre incalculable de touristes bref
une aubaine pour le territoire
nous avons interviewé le directeur du
golf national
le golf a pris une véritable ampleur là
ces derniers temps absolument
depuis l'annnonce en 2011 que on allait
accueillir la ryder cup on a passé une
ryder cup en écosse et puis une aux
états unis maintenant les yeux sont
rivés sur la france un conte un saint
quentin en yvelines et le golf national
oui j'imagine qu'en termes économiques a
beaucoup de choses qui avancent qu'il ya
l'open de france là qui arrive ça va
générer quoi exactement par l'open de
france déjà appris
une vitesse supérieure cette année grâce
notamment à la ryder cup puisqu'on est
passé dans une autre division de
tournois sur le circuit mondial circuits
mondiaux pardon et européens on est
passé dans ce qu'on appelle maintenant
les rolex series on a doublé la dotation
pour les joueurs ce qui rajoute encore
de visibilité des médias comme vous
puisque en double nombre d'heures de
direct sur une centaine de pays au monde
et à volume d'activité plus important en
général
parlez-moi de cette activité même du
tourisme on en parle est un petit coup
avant ça donne quoi
moi je peux vous donner quelques
chiffres en 2014 par exemple quand je
suis arrivé le golfe on faisait environ
40000 euros de chiffre d'affaires avec
des tour opérateurs à l'étranger veut en
france et ce chiffre va atteindre cette
année 300 milles d'accord ça donne une
idée de la croissance ce n'est pas la
totalité des excuses en serre exact est
exactement mais en termes d'activité
avec des touristes
incoming c'est l'explosion j'imagine que
les hôtels autour séduire la crise non
mais tout le monde en bénéficie
nous avons par exemple sur le novotel
sur site
rajoutez uniquement l'année dernière
1200 nuitées de plus donc cet acte rec
attractivité du golfe apporte aussi du
business pour les commerces à côté mais
il ya aussi la ryder cup alors j'imagine
qu'il était question qu'on ne peut pas
vous poser mais en terme économique ça
va vraiment explosé c'est vraiment ce
que vous attendez oui j'ai pas de
chiffres à vous donner mais je peux vous
donner par exemple le fait qu'on espère
avoir soixante mille 61000 très
exactement de spectateurs par jour
plus il y aura entre cinq et huit mille
personnes qui travaillent sur
l'événement sur site donc on n'est pas
loin les soixante dix mille personnes
par jour pendant cinq jours sur le site
vous multipliez ça par le nombre de
repas nécessaires par le nombre de
nuitées par des transports en commun
voire des taxis et cetera
vous imaginez ce que ça génère comme
puis d'affaires pour la région et la
création de richesse pour le pays c'est
ça en fait il ya le golfe mais aussi le
territoire de 50 ans qui ont profité
évidemment évidemment jusqu'à paris mais
localement les restaurants peuvent
attendre à avoir beaucoup de monde dans
la semaine de la ryder cup mais aussi
dans les trois mois qui précèdent la
ryder cup là-bas avoir plus de 200 300
personnes qui travaillent sur
l'événement et pour les gens qui
viennent jouer ici ça va qu'est ce que
ça va apporter en plus les inscriptions
ont augmenté parce que là vous augmentez
la rue en mai on appris en a pris en a
fait le choix en fin 2014 d'augmenter
nos prix à ce moment là donc il ya déjà
trois ans et ça c'est derrière nous donc
les augmentations de prix entre
guillemets sont derrière nous mais on
n'a pas augmenté parce que y'a la ryder
cup pour parce que ya l'open de france
en a augmenté simplement parce qu'on
avait oublié d'augmenter pendant 10-15
entre huy ha vu comme ça voilà et donc
l'augmentation c'est que le prix normal
est maintenant le prix avantageux ou
anormales c'était avant l'accord et ça
sert maintenant reconnu et connu un peu
dans les différents milieux golfique que
nous avons une gamme de produits en à
l'albatros qui le parcourent la ryder
cup qui est positionnée dans le haut de
gamme c'est vrai on à l'aigle 18 trous
magnifiquement bien entretenu un
parcours sympa pour la région pour les
locaux dans les prix du marché voient en
légèrement en dessous bien placé et on a
loiselet de neuf trous qui est notre
fleurant pour le démocratisation du golf
et le développement du golf c'est à dire
vous pouvez jouer au golf là bas autant
que vous voulez par mois pour 50 euros
par exemple la galerie d'une salle de
sport ben je vous remercie de nous avoir
reçus
voilà merci merci à vous c'est la fin de
ce sept huit et commercy nous avoir
suivis et bonne soirée
[Musique]